[INTENSE MUSIC]
I got him.
[EXPLOSION]
[SOFT DRAMATIC MUSIC]
Going to move your foot here.
Point your toe this way.
Yes.
Here.
OK?
Mind your elbow.
[LAUGHS] Good job, Hawkeye.
[INTENSE MUSIC]
[SCREAMING]
(OFF-SCREEN) Cooper!
Where are my headphones?
Lila?
[BEEPING]
Lila!
[SOFT INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
Yeah, Dad?
It worked.
[SOFT INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
[INTENSE MUSIC]
Just like Budapest
all over again.
You and I remember
Budapest very differently.
You want me to
slow him down, sir?
Or are you sending in more
guys for him to beat up?
I'll let you know.
You better call it,
Coulson, because I'm
starting to root for this guy.
[SOFT INSTRUMENTAL MUSIC]
I guess I should have knocked.
Oh, my God.
What are you doing here?
Disappointing my kids.
We're supposed to
go water skiing.
Cap needs our help.
Come on.
[SOFT DRAMATIC MUSIC]
Clint, can you get him off me?
Buckled in?
Yeah.
No, I'm good.
I'm good, arrow guy.
Let's go.
Let's go!
[INTENSE MUSIC]
Whatever it takes.
[SOFT DRAMATIC MUSIC]
If we don't get that stone,
billions of people stay dead.
Then I guess we both
know who it's got to be.
I guess we do.
[SOFT DRAMATIC MUSIC]
The city is flying.
We're fighting an
army of robots.
And I have a bow and arrow.
None of this makes sense.
Ahh!
But I'm going back out
there because it's my job.
OK?
And I can't do my
job and babysit.
Doesn't matter what you
did or what you were.
If you go out there, you
fight, and you fight to kill.
Stay in here, you're good.
I'll send your brother
to come find you.
But if you step out that
door, you are an Avenger.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
[INTENSE MUSIC]
[GROANS]
Authorities are wondering
if the masked vigilante
who terrorized the city's
underworld is back.
When I wore this suit, I
made a whole lot of enemies.
You're Hawkeye!
Who are you?
Some people have
actually called
me the world's greatest archer.
[RUMBLING]
This is too dangerous.
Definitely not this one.
You don't have to say
"definitely" like that.
There are arrows more
dangerous than that one?
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]